[Music]
icarly was one of our favorite shows on
Nickelodeon when we were young but as we
grow up we understand that there are
many inappropriate jokes that we missed
simply because they can only be
understood by adults make sure you watch
this video until the end to know which
funny symbol was hidden in almost all
the episodes if you love icarly as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 15 funniest
adult jokes in iCarly you might have
missed the pointy boobs it was the first
episode of iCarly and we already heard
one inappropriate adult joke this is why
our parents didn't like the show and why
we loved it even more we knew that Carly
was going to be a bad girl as the first
thing she did was getting into trouble
because she puts ahead of a teacher on
the body of a rhinoceros this is why she
and her best friend Sam had to spend the
weekend at school to host the auditions
for the talent show one of the students
performing was a young guy with no sense
of humor and they quickly compared him
to miss Briggs
except he doesn't have MS Briggs crazy
pointy boobs Carly even said that it's
like she stuffs waffle cones in her bra
and then Sam added that she could poke
an eye with one of those things little
did she know Freddie filmed them and
posted what they said online
we really don't understand how
Nickelodeon got away with that the
teacher the three friends really have
some problems with authority and it just
got worse when Carly and Freddie decided
to break into an apartment in I spy a
mean teacher they couldn't believe that
teachers have a life outside school and
this is why they decided to know more
about miss Briggs by spying on her
unfortunately they cut a little too much
information when they hid in her
apartment and saw what she was doing
when she was alone at home she started
making weird noises and they quickly
understood that she was just exercising
but wait it got weirder the two kids
found a room full of Randy Jackson's
when we thought that miss Briggs
couldn't be more obsessed she started
talking to a cardboard cutout and
putting her butt between his legs we
guess this is why we don't want to know
what
teachers are doing outside of school we
think that we prefer Ms Briggs when she
is mean the balls just when we thought
that this episode couldn't get more
inappropriate we heard another adult
joke
Spencer was talking with his new
girlfriend and asked her to do something
for him we all thought that he was
asking for something many young men want
from a beautiful girl but we were
actually really surprised the girls
started juggling with three balls and
Spencer was really happy unfortunately
it didn't take too long before they
broke up Spencer said that it was
because he found out that she was
juggling four other boys it's not only a
way to say that she was cheating but
many grown-ups imagined that she was
juggling other men's balls anyway when
she tried to impress other boys this
girl got what she deserved the guy
couldn't stop watching iCarly and she
was upset because she didn't get enough
attention that's what you get for
cheating on Spencer his little sister
will always be there to protect him the
chick Carly took a break from
inappropriate jokes until the 16th
episode of the first season I had chicks
this time Carly and Sam decided to hatch
a bunch of baby chickens they got some
fertilized chicken eggs put them in an
incubator and watch the little chicks
come to life
however these tiny creatures quickly
escaped and started running all around
the house this is how Spencer Carly's
older brother found one in the shower he
said that he picked it up thinking it
was a bar of soap then he said that it
was a good thing he realized what it was
before never mind we can only imagine
what Spencer tried to clean with this
baby chicken and we are already
terrified moreover it sounds like there
was a chick down there with him in the
shower it is even more wrong when you
think that this word can be used to
refer to a woman anyway how did he even
think it was a bar of soap the idea and
we couldn't in the first season without
another inappropriate joke in I win a
date Spencer broke up with another girl
just after a blind date
simply because he didn't like her and
also because she had an imaginary pet
unicorn anyway Carly convinced her big
brother to try online dating and post a
video online he tried to look like the
perfect man he tried to be sporty and
then he tried eating cereals for no
minutes straight as we expected none of
this worked this is why Spencer decided
to take a shower because he always gets
his best ideas when he's wet we know
that he was probably referring to water
but out of context adults couldn't keep
themselves from thinking about what he
meant by being wet
maybe that's actually what he was doing
in the shower anyway we don't want to be
thinking about that and we are happy
that he got the attention of some women
in prison with his cereal video the
couch our parents thought that season
two started out really well with no
inappropriate jokes and then they saw I
pie and they quickly changed their mind
this time the friends wanted to go eat
pie for breakfast they loved it so much
that they kept asking for more dessert
but there were no more pies this was
when they learned that the guy making
pies passed away and that the restaurant
was going to close because no one needs
a secret recipe except for his
granddaughter trudy
Carly asked Spencer to use his charm to
talk to her he offered her money but
what she really wanted was to go out a
date with him and this is how they ended
up together
Spencer was already uncomfortable when
Trudy asked him to move this party to
the couch all the grown-ups know what it
means
Spencer replied that the couch was
broken and this is when the weird girl
suggested that they could break it some
more now we think that even kids
understood this joke though word you
want to hear this one because this is
probably the most inappropriate joke we
ever heard on Nickelodeon in I rocked
the vote the three friends got the
chance to work with a young man who
participated in America sings
actually they thought that they had a
chance until they realized that Wade
Collins was really a diva they just
wanted to help him after making him lose
the competition but Carly Sam and
Freddie
ended up being the losers Freddie said
that it was hard to find the footage of
the singer not screaming at him and that
he even called him an untalented
hobknocker when Carly asked what it
meant
Sam whispered in her ear and she replied
that it was gross her friend even added
that it was illegal
if you don't understand what hobknocker
means we suggest you don't try to find
out about it on the internet unless you
are more than 18 years old this is not
even appropriate for adults so we really
wonder how you
majors learn this word the squirrels
after such an inappropriate joke the
three friends were nicer for many
episodes until I believe in Bigfoot this
time we discovered that Carly was
totally obsessed with Bigfoot when
watching the footage on TV she was sure
that this creature was real even though
many people didn't believe her and to
prove that she was right before friends
decided to go on an adventure and look
for Bigfoot looking in the forest Carly
saw something moving and realized that
it was only two squirrels wrestling
this was when Freddie corrected her by
saying that they were not fighting and
his friend took another look before she
understood what they were doing only
grownups know what it is but that's not
all in the same episode
Spencer was talking about a female
beaver and a male raccoon socializing by
a river when he was looking for a
creature called the beavecoon
it seems like these animals are all
single and ready to mingle the fight
fans of iCarly had to wait for another
season of the show to see another adult
joke and they were not disappointed the
four friends decided to go to webicon
and spencer took the opportunity to
dress as one of his favorite characters
and visit the world of warlords
he's ought that he was going to win the
competition until he saw another guy
wearing a costume this is why Spencer
decided to prove that he was the best
and they quickly started a fight the two
guys started insulting each other and
singing until things got way too far
they used their weapons to prove that
they were stronger than the other
Spencer used a long stab and the other
guy replied with two wrist balls
we don't know about you but a long stick
and two balls remind us of what only men
have this joke is really subtle but we
think that many adults understood what
it was supposed to represent the oil
season 5 started in the best way with
another inappropriate joke we can never
get enough of them first Carly says that
Sam's mom was having the laser hair
removal Spencer asked on what body part
and his sister said that she didn't want
to know were they talking about one
specific body part anyway that's not the
joke we wanted to talk about Spencer was
stuck in Carly's pants and wanted to use
olive oil to get out
of it when he asked this sister where it
was she answered that it was in the
bathroom where he left it but what has
he been doing with it many adults
understood that he probably needed a
little bit of lubrication while having
fun and that is something that no sister
should ever know about we guessed that
he'll be putting oil in his pants once
again to get out of these jeans and we
don't want to be there to see it this
time the restaurant just as we heard an
inappropriate joke another one was
coming in the following episode I date
Sam and Freddie
in this episode Carly and Gibby we're
spending more time together while Sam
and Freddie were trying to get to know
each other actually they were mostly
fighting but they found a way to make it
cute this is why the couple asked their
two friends to go on a date with them
Freddie invited them to a restaurant
called penes and Gibby replied that he
loves penes we don't know about you but
we think that it really sounds like the
name of a body part that only men have
and Gibby seem to be really enthusiastic
about it Sam even said that lasagna at
pinis is so good that she wants to be
buried in a bathtub full of penes
lasagna and we think that it sounds
wrong to be a bathtub with so many
pennies no matter what this restaurant
gets a lot of attention simply because
of its name so good for them the wind
with an episode named eyeballs we knew
that we were going to see something
wrong first Spencer talked about taking
a girl the penes once again but we have
another joke for you if you watched this
episode you know that Spencer got a
personal assistant to help him do stuff
and things
so this nice guy followed him everywhere
to do whatever he wanted unfortunately
every good thing one day comes to an end
and the personal assistant had to quit
his job he said that he would miss
Spencer and he asked him where he would
go this was when he answered that he was
going to go whichever way the wind blows
him and Spencer replied that he hopes it
blows him someplace wonderful if you
know what blowing someone means you can
understand that saying that was actually
really inappropriate for a kids show at
least we guessed that the personal
assistant will appreciate that or maybe
he will just be blown back into the
men's room the show nothing
inappropriate happened in the sixth
season and then we couldn't believe that
it was already the last season of
Carly but no matter what we were happy
to know that there were going to be two
more inappropriate jokes and one of them
was in I shocked America when we saw
Jimmy Fallon we knew that it was going
to be a great show mostly when Spencer
saw that the host loved icarly carly and
sam talked about jimmy fallon and this
is how they got the chance to be invited
on the show
unfortunately they totally ruined this
beautiful opportunity that's because
Gibby dropped his pants when dancing and
unfortunately for the audience he was
not wearing any underwear
we know that he loves penis but that was
not a reason to show it it was really
awkward we can't imagine how terrified
the people in the audience were and we
guessed that Jimmy Fallon is not going
to invite them again the book it was the
second last episode of our favorite
sitcom and we were ready for one last
inappropriate joke Spencer went to funk
confessed her and learned that he
couldn't enter the room unless he was
with a kid this is why he had guppy by
his side and while the grown-up was
playing games to win a prize the kid had
to wait at the table and read a book but
wait until you see what copy was reading
just look at the title of the book it is
called 50 shades of beige don't you
think that it reminds you of something
it looks just like the popular novel
Fifty Shades of Grey and if you know
about it you know that this is
absolutely not a book for children if
Nifty shades of beige is anything like
that we understand why guppy had that
strange look on his face the apartment
can you believe that there was one joke
that we saw in a lot of episodes but
many people didn't realize that it was
inappropriate it was there since the
first episode if you look at Freddy's
apartment you will see a strange symbol
next to his door it is 8d and no it is
not a random flat number if you are a
grown-up who likes flirting on the phone
with your partner you know what it means
it represents something men have between
their legs
unfortunately icarly is over so we won't
see any more inappropriate jokes but
knowing about what you missed is just a
good reason to watch the show once again
are there any other adult jokes that we
missed and icarly if you found one don't
be shy to tell us what it is in the
comment section down below we love to
know what you think
and that's it for 15 funniest jokes in
iCarly you might have missed for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
inappropriate jokes in good luck charlie
thanks for watching
[Music]